>> Bret: FULL COVERAGE OF THAT
HEARING TOMORROW.
THANKS.
A SHORT TIME AGO I TALKED WITH
JUDGE KAVANAUGH'S ATTORNEY, BETH
WILKINSON.
>> Bret: THERE ARE NO CALLS,
NOT ONLY THE SENATE MINORITY
LEADER CHUCK SCHUMER, BUT ALL
TEN DEMOCRATS ON THE SENATE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE ARE CALLING
FOR KAVANAUGH TO WITHDRAW HIS
NOMINATION.
IS HE CONSIDERING THAT AT ALL?
>> NO, HE'S NOT.
AND IT'S VERY UNFORTUNATE THAT
IT'S COME TO THIS TODAY.
I'M SHOCKED BY THE ALLEGATIONS,
EXTRAORDINARY THAT THEY WERE
JUST DROPPED ON THE PUBLIC TODAY
AND ON THE COMMITTEE.
IF YOU READ THOSE ALLEGATIONS,
THEY MEAN THAT TENS AND TENS OF
MEN AND WOMEN WERE INVOLVED WITH
GANG RAPE AND BINGE DRINKING AND
NO ONE REPORTED IT AND NO ONE
REPORTED THAT SINCE JUDGE
KAVANAUGH HAS BEEN IN THIS
PROCESS.
IF THIS ALLEGATION HAS MERIT, I
DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY HER
ATTORNEY DIDN'T BRING IT FORWARD
BEFORE AND WHY HE HASN'T GONE TO
THE POLICE.
>> Bret: THE DEMOCRATS ARE
SAYING WHY NOT JUST PUT THE
BRAKES ON EVERYTHING UNTIL THE
FBI TO REOPEN THIS BACKGROUND
INVESTIGATION?
>> THAT'S UP TO THE SENATE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
>> Bret: THEY SAY IT'S UP TO
JUDGE KAVANAUGH.
>> IT'S REALLY NOT.
IF THE SENATE IS IN CHARGE OF
THIS PROCESS.
THEY RUN THE INVESTIGATION, THEY
RUN THE HEARING.
HE HAS SAID WHAT HE KNOWS, WHICH
IS HE ABSOLUTELY DIDN'T DO THIS.
HE DOESN'T EVEN KNOW THIS WOMAN
AND HE HAS SUBMITTED HIMSELF TO
QUESTIONS UNDER THE PENALTY OF
PERJURY OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
HE SAID REPEATEDLY HE'S NEVER
ENGAGED IN THIS KIND OF CONDUCT.
AND I WONDER WHY THESE PEOPLE
DIDN'T COME FORWARD WHEN JUDGE
KAVANAUGH HAS BEEN IN THE
LIMELIGHT FOR MONTHS.
MONTHS AND IF THEY THOUGHT THESE
ALLEGATIONS HAD ANY MERIT THEY
SHOULD HAVE COME FORWARD BEFORE
AND THERE WOULD HAVE BEEN PLENTY
OF TIME TO DO WHATEVER THEY WANT
TO DO.
BUT YOU HAVE TO QUESTION THE
MOTIVES WHEN THEY COME FORWARD
WITH THE MOST SALACIOUS, MOST
OUTRAGEOUS ALLEGATIONS THE DAY
BEFORE THE HEARING.
>> Bret: SENATOR FLAKE SAID
TODAY ON A SPEECH ON THE SENATE
FLOOR THAT NO MATTER WHAT
HAPPENS, EVEN IF THEY GET TO A
"YES" AND NO VOTE, THAT THIS IS
GOING TO HAVE SOME DOUBTS
SURROUNDING IT.
>> I UNDERSTAND WHAT HE'S SAYING
BECAUSE THIS PROCESS, WHAT IT'S
BECOME SO DEMEANING AND
DEGRADING FOR OUR COUNTRY.
I DON'T KNOW WHY ANYONE WOULD
EVER WANT TO PUT THEIR NAME IN
THE HAT FOR PUBLIC OFFICE
ANYMORE IF WE ARE GOING TO DO
THIS FOR PEOPLE.
I THINK THERE IS GOING TO BE A
PAIL OVER EVERYONE FOR HOW THEY
PARTICIPATED IN THIS AND IF YOU
WOULDN'T HAUL OUT AND MAKE
ACCUSATIONS AGAINST SOMEONE THE
DAY BEFORE THEY WERE GOING IN
FRONT OF THE HEARING, YOU JUST
WOULDN'T DO THAT.
NORMAL PEOPLE -- EVEN WHEN THERE
ARE OPPOSED TO JUDGE KAVANAUGH,
WHICH THEY HAVE EVERY RIGHT TO
BE, WOULD NEVER DO THAT.
IT JUST MAKES EVERYBODY LOOK
LIKE THEY ARE POLITICIZING THE
SUPREME COURT AND THE APPROVAL
PROCESS.
>> Bret: I TALKED TO A LOT OF
PEOPLE AND THEY SAY IT JUST
FEELS BAD NO MATTER WHAT SIDE
YOU'RE ON.
LISTENING TO JUDGE KAVANAUGH AND
HIS WIFE ON THE INTERVIEW WITH
MARTHA THE OTHER NIGHT, IS HE
MORE INDIGNANT, ANGRY?
>> I KNOW HE'S VERY UPSET ABOUT
IT BECAUSE HE KNOWS HE DIDN'T DO
IT, BUT HE'S A JUDGE.
HE'S NOT A TELEVISION PERSON,
HE'S NOT A TRIAL LAWYER LIKE I
AM SO HE'S NOT USED TO TALKING
ABOUT THESE THINGS AND BEING ON
TELEVISION AND IT'S I THINK
EMBARRASSING IN FRONT OF HIS
FAMILY AND HIS TWO DAUGHTERS TO
TALK ABOUT THAT HE DRANK AT
TIMES IN EXCESS WHEN HE WAS IN
COLLEGE, DATING GIRLS AND WHAT
HAPPENED.
IT'S NOT A COMFORTABLE POSITION.
IF THAT DOESN'T MEAN HE DOESN'T
HAVE TO ANSWER THE QUESTIONS.
HE UNDERSTANDS THAT COMES WITH
THE JOB INTERVIEW AND HE'S NOT
SAYING FEEL SORRY FOR HIM, BUT
HE'S OUTRAGED BY THIS MOST
RECENT ALLEGATION BECAUSE IT
SUGGESTS THAT FOR YEARS, YEARS,
THERE WAS GANG RAPE GOING ON AND
NO ONE SAID ANYTHING, A
MULTITUDE OF WOMEN AND A LARGE
NUMBER OF MEN WERE INVOLVED.
IT DOESN'T SAY HE WAS INVOLVED,
IT SAYS HE WAS PRESENT, WHICH HE
WAS NOT.
HE DOESN'T EVEN KNOW THIS WOMAN,
BUT THIS IS A WHOLE DIFFERENT
LEVEL OF ALLEGATION.
>> Bret: WE'RE IN THIS
ENVIRONMENT, OBVIOUSLY, PEOPLE
ARE BEING TOLD THAT THEY NEED TO
COME FORWARD.
2 OUT OF 3 DON'T REALLY TALK
ABOUT IT, BUT HERE YOU HAVE THE
END OF THE LINE AND THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF WOMEN COMING FORWARD.
>> I THINK SOME OF THE WOMEN
DIDN'T WANT TO COME FORWARD.
AS I UNDERSTAND FOR DR. BLASEY
FORWARD, SHE DIDN'T WANT TO COME
FORWARD.
I FEEL SORRY FOR HER.
I FEEL SORRY FOR ANYONE WHO IS
ASSOCIATED WITH THIS PROCESS,
MARC SHORT, JUDGE KAVANAUGH IS
FRIENDS WITH, SOME OF THE OTHER
PEOPLE WHO WERE SUPPOSEDLY AT
THIS PARTY THAT EVERYONE SAYS
DID NOT HAPPEN AND THEY DON'T
RECALL IT AND IT'S OF COURSE NOT
CONSISTENT WITH JUDGE KAVANAUGH
OR WHAT THEY KNOW ABOUT HIM, BUT
EVERYBODY IS DEMEANED BY THIS
PROCESS AND SOMEBODY LEAKED THAT
INFORMATION, I DON'T UNDERSTAND
WHY THIS INFORMATION BROUGHT
FORWARD BY MICHAEL AVENATTI WAS
HELD BACK UNTIL TODAY.
AND I UNDERSTAND WHY IT MAKES
EVERYONE FEEL UNCOMFORTABLE,
BECAUSE SEXUAL ASSAULT IS A VERY
SERIOUS CLAIM AND IT'S DIFFICULT
FOR WOMEN TO TALK ABOUT IT.
AND IT SHOULDN'T BE POLITICIZED
ON EITHER SIDE.
IT IS NOT FAIR TO THE WOMEN AND
IT IS NOT FAIR TO THE MEN WHO
CAN BE ACCUSED OR WRONGLY
ACCUSED.
>> Bret: SO WHEN THEY KEEP
SAYING IT NEEDS TO BE
INVESTIGATED BY THE FBI, WHAT IS
THIS?
>> WHY DIDN'T THEY CALL THE
POLICE?
THE DAY MR. MENOTTI STARTED
REPRESENTING HER, NO ONE STOPPED
HIM FROM GOING TO THE POLICE OR
THE FBI.
THE SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
JUST IN TIME THE PHONE NUMBERS
OF THE FBI.
HE KNOWS WHAT HE'S DOING.
>> Bret: ALSO TODAY, THE
LAWYER FOR DR. BLASEY FORD AHEAD
OF THIS TESTIMONY PUT OUT --
SHE'S NOT GOING TO PUT UP THE
MEDICAL RECORDS ON THE NOTES BUT
SHE DID PUT OUT THE POLYGRAPH
THAT SHE APPARENTLY TOOK ON
AUGUST 7TH THE COMES TO THE
CONCLUSION ACCORDING TO THIS
PAPERWORK THAT IT'S NOT
INDICATIVE OF DECEPTION, HER
ANSWERS TO THIS POLYGRAPH, DOES
THAT MEAN ANYTHING TO YOU?
>> THAT WAS UP TO DR. BLASEY.
SHE HAS HER REASONS FOR NOT
WANTING TO COME FORWARD BEFORE
AND THAT'S UP TO HER.
BUT THE NOTES THAT I READ ABOUT
IN "THE WASHINGTON POST" WHERE
THAT THERE WERE NOTES THAT HER
THERAPIST MADE IN COUPLES
THERAPY AND THAT THEY DON'T SEEM
TO MATCH UP WITH WHAT PEOPLE ARE
SAYING ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED NOW.
THOSE WOULD BE RELEVANT BECAUSE
THAT WAS THE FIRST TIME SHE
SUPPOSEDLY EVER TALKED ABOUT
THIS AND I WOULD HOPE THAT THEY
WOULD TURN OVER THE NOTES BUT OF
COURSE THEY ARE SAYING THEIR
MEDICAL RECORDS, THEY DON'T WANT
TO DO THAT.
THAT'S UP TO THEM.
>> Bret: SHE OBVIOUSLY SAID
SHE WANTED TO BE ANONYMOUS BUT
IN AUGUST, TAKES THE POLYGRAPH,
HIRES AN ATTORNEY, WHAT IS THE
THINKING ABOUT THE REASONING?
>> I THINK WHAT'S OUT HERE IS
JUDGE KAVANAUGH KNOWS HE DIDN'T
DO THIS AND WHEN THESE
ALLEGATIONS COME OUT OF THE LAST
MINUTE IT'S ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE TO
DISPROVE WHEN SOMEONE SAYS THAT
AT THE LAST MINUTE.
>> Bret: IS HE WORRIED THAT
SHE'S GOING TO COME OFF AS
CREDIBLE IN HIS HEARING AND THAT
THEY'RE GOING TO LOSE ONE OR TWO
VOTES?
>> HONESTLY HE'S NOT THINKING
ABOUT HER OTHER THAN I THINK HE
UNDERSTANDS THAT SHE DIDN'T WANT
TO BE PUBLIC ABOUT THIS EITHER.
HE WANTS TO COME FORWARD IN
FRONT OF THE AMERICAN PUBLIC AND
EXPLAIN THAT HE DIDN'T DO THIS
UNTIL ANSWERS ANY QUESTIONS THAT
THE SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
HAS UNTIL TELL THE TRUTH AND
THAT'S THE BEST HE CAN DO.
HE DOESN'T LIKE THE PROCESS, HOW
IT'S TURNED OUT, BUT HE
UNDERSTANDS THAT THAT'S HIS
OBLIGATION AND HE'S GOING TO DO
IT AND HE'S ANSWERED THOSE
QUESTIONS BEFORE AND HE'LL
ANSWER THEM AGAIN.
>> Bret: AND DOES HE WORRY AT
ALL ABOUT GETTING ON THE
SUPREME COURT AND THEN SOMEHOW
THIS DOESN'T STOP AND THAT THEY
GO AFTER HIM CONTINUALLY FOR
IMPEACHMENT OR SOMETHING ELSE?
>> I THINK WE ALL WORRY THAT IF
WE LOSE THE DIGNITY OF THE
PROCESS IT CAN AFFECT THE
SUPREME COURT AND EVERYBODY
INVOLVED, BUT I THINK AT THIS
POINT HE HAS HAD INVESTIGATION
AFTER INVESTIGATION.
HE'S HAD A LONG PERIOD MARK WITH
THE PUBLIC WAS ALLOWED TO LOOK
AT HIM, ASK QUESTIONS TO THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
IF SENATORS HAVE ASKED HIM
QUESTIONS IN PUBLIC AND PRIVATE.
ALL THAT HAS TAKEN PLACE AND ALL
THAT WAS THERE FOR A REASON.
PEOPLE ARE THERE TO DECIDE WHAT
THEY THINK AND WHETHER THE
SENATORS WILL VOTE FOR HIM OR
NOT AND THEY'RE ALLOWED TO DO
THAT.
BUT IT CAN'T BE THAT WHEN PEOPLE
MAKE LAST-MINUTE ALLEGATIONS AND
THROW CHARACTER ASSASSINATION AT
HIM THAT THERE FOR THE ANSWER TO
STEP BACK AND DO NOT GO FORWARD.
THESE PEOPLE DESERVE TO HAVE
THEIR HEARING IN THE SENATORS
DESERVE TO VOTE AS THEY THINK
THEY SHOULD.
>> Bret: AND HE'S IN IT FOR
THE LONG HAUL.
>> YES.